blazer a ui framework for building
front-end web applications with html css
and not javascript but c-sharp by
leveraging the power of webassembly it's
able to eliminate javascript from your
front-end stack it was created at
microsoft in 2018 by steve sanderson the
developer famous for creating knockout
js years earlier just like react and
other modern ui libraries you build
components called razer components that
encapsulate parts of the user interface
what makes blazer special is its ability
to blur the lines between client and
server thanks to wasm you can run c
sharp code with your favorite.net
libraries in the browser or
alternatively run your client side code
on the server and stream changes back
into the dom via signal ir a tool built
on top of websockets for real-time
communication in addition blazer
components are capable of running on any
platform with dotnet maui you can reuse
your code natively on ios android or
desktop now if you're not convinced
c-sharp can get the job done by itself
it can easily interop with javascript on
both the client and server to get
started install visual studio with
asp.net capabilities then generate a new
blazer webassembly project the root of
your application contains a router in
the app.razer file notice how it's
structured with a variety of built-in
components like router and layout view
that don't need to be explicitly
imported like a javascript app now
create a new page by adding a razer
component to the pages directory at the
top of that file add the page directive
to specify the url pattern we can then
add a title using a built-in razer
component or simply add some plain html
here but now it's time to add some
reactive state to this application which
can be accomplished with the code
directive which allows us to write logic
with the industrial strength reliability
of c sharp define a property like count
then use it in a template with the at
symbol the value is reactive so any time
it changes the template will re-render
we can add a method to the code to
increment the count then bind it to a
button as the on click event handler now
to make the component look pretty add a
matching css file and all the styles
here will be scoped to that component
now when it comes to sharing logic and
state between components blazer has
dependency injection built in which
allows you to write a class in one place
then inject it into any component using
the inject directive in addition when
you add a component to the shared
directory it can be used instantly
throughout the entire application and
not only runs on the web but virtually
any native platform now use net run to
compile the web assembly and view your
web app in the browser this has been
blazer in 100 seconds hit the like
button if you want to see more short
videos like this thanks for watching and
i will see you in the next one